poroshenko said this was a historic step  but he asked the EU to go further and  promised that Ukraine will one day be  allowed to become a member over the last  month Ukraine paid a highest possible  price to make her European dreams come  true it must be worth something for  instance to finally consider a simple  statement of the part of the EU once  Ukraine would be ready it will be in a  statement that could cost you nothing  but would mean the world of my country  the EU signed similar agreements with  Moldova and Georgia the plan is for all  three former Soviet states eventually to  be able to trade completely freely with  EU countries once they comply with EU  standards